let's take a break from the Trump news
for a second we've been talking for
years about how to reduce the number of
abortions I am someone who is pro-choice
but I would like to reduce the number of
abortions to zero if possible and we
know what to do if fewer people get
pregnant in situations where they don't
want to have a child or for whatever
reason it would be a bad idea for them
to have a child you're going to reduce
the number of people who want abortions
and thus reduce the number of people who
seek out and get abortions we know that
comprehensive sex education combined
with access to contraception and the
knowledge about what to do with it is
how you reduce unintended pregnancy and
thus how you reduce abortion Republicans
conservatives religious rightists they
say they want to reduce abortion but
then they oppose comprehensive sex ed
and access to contraception
well the abortion rate is at an all-time
low and it has nothing to do with
attempts to quote ban abortion by the
Religious Right and Republicans it has
everything to do with better and
increased access to birth control u.s.
women are having abortions at the lowest
rate since 1973 which is the year of the
decision roe v wade which legalized
abortion and even though the american
right continues to say we have an
abortion crisis of historic proportions
the abortion rate has been declining for
decades let's take a look at a graph
about this and as you can see since
reaching a high in roughly nineteen
eighty is what it looks like according
to this graph we have seen a steady and
continued reduction in the abortion rate
and interestingly when you look at the
raw numbers the number of recorded
abortions fell below a million for the
first time since the mid 1970s in the
most recent year for which we have data
which I believe is 2014 this is
particularly notable because the
population today is way bigger than it
was in the 1970s and yet we still have
in the aggregate a very very low number
of abortions and of course that just
tells us how drastically the rate has
been reduced so why has this happened I
sort of alluded to it already better
access to high-quality birth control
living in cultures that treat
contraception as less taboo this is a
fascinating reality pad if you look at
the countries where there's limited
access to legal abortion and both
abortion and birth control are more
taboo like in developing African
countries in some Asian countries in
some Latin American countries where
abortions are both difficult to come by
and also highly highly stigmatized
abortion rates have not gone down over
the last several decades the decrease in
the worldwide abortion rate has been
driven by the countries where abortions
are less taboo and we're both abortion
services and birth control are more
accessible think about that for a second
the so-called pro lifers want fewer
abortions yet we are seeing abortions
lower than they've been in decades in
the u.s. because we have more sex
education more access to birth control
both things that the rightists don't
want and if it's really about lowering
the number of abortions which I think
everyone can agree is the goal that we
should have yeah I think people on the
right should come around to this idea
because treating it as less taboo and
increasing the amount of people Isis
people can go to tracing sexual
education and contraception programs
that's what's going to do that yeah and
they don't care it's part partially
based in this sort of strict father
morality religious idea where birth
control is like a cheat code in a video
game right no no no if you are actually
going to not have an abortion it needs
to be because of abstinence only sex
education or your religious values or
except accepting Jesus into wherever you
need to accept accept a man to prevent
pregnancy from happening they see birth
control as a cheat code of swords they
see sex education as something that will
corrupt our children's minds think about
this statement from the researchers in
this study which is exactly what I've
been saying for years fewer women had
abortions in 2011 than in 2008 because
fewer women became pregnant when they
didn't want to mind-blowing absolutely
mind-blowing so let's explore what the
anti-choice errs will
when they read this report they'll say
oh you know what if you look at the US
the decrease in abortions must be in the
states of the United States
that passed abortion restrictions
flat-out untrue
let's take a look at our next graphic
pad and you will see that there is no
pattern between the abortion rate going
up or down and abortion restrictions
being passed and for people who aren't
looking at this graph with me number one
if you look at the states where there
have been larger than average declines
in the abortion rate there are actually
more states on that list that did not
pass new abortion restrictions than
those that did if you look at a bigger
list of states that had a modest decline
in the abortion rate you will again see
that a majority of them passed no new
abortion restrictions and lastly there
are seven states which from 2011 to 2014
saw an increase in the abortion rate of
the seven states that saw an increase in
the abortion rate for passed new
abortion restrictions and yet the
abortion rate still went up this is
relevant why it's relevant because under
Trump we may see strong attempts to
completely ban abortion at the federal
level Supreme Court roe v wade a side
pat we have a new bill introduced by
lunatic Republican Congressman Steve
King from Iowa it's HR 490 it would
prohibit all abortions at the federal
level as soon as a fetal heartbeat is
detected that can be as early as six
weeks into the pregnancy this can be
before some women even know they're
pregnant this is effectively a total
abortion ban this is what we have to
look forward to and I think Roe versus
Wade being overturned isn't completely
off the table regardless of what Donald
Trump's position on abortion is he
claims to be pro-life but even just as
recent as a decade ago he claimed to be
pro-choice more doesn't matter because
if he puts people on the Supreme Court
and has a litmus test and makes sure
that they are in favor of eliminating
abortions and being pro-life what does
that matter in the end yeah ultimately
it's going to depend on who is on the
Supreme Court and Donald Trump will have
a role to play in that and whether there
is a concerted effort to get a case up
to the Supreme Court during a time when
the Supreme Court may lean in the
choice direction this could get really
bad I'll have more information about
that bill for you if it looks like it
might have a shot at becoming federal
law send me your thoughts about this I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show let me
know what you think about this today's
program is made possible in part by blue
apron I love cooking at home I would say
that I cook at home probably in just
about every weekday at minimum and one
of the things I sometimes run into is I
know I'll want to make something and I
buy the ingredients I need for it but I
end up with leftover ingredients and I
didn't properly plan for other recipes
to use the rest of that ingredient in
and although I do everything I can to
prevent throwing food out sometimes I
end up with food that I didn't use that
goes bad and that's what I love about
blue apron you select the meals you want
for the week and then you get a shipment
from blue apron with the exact amount of
each ingredient that's necessary for the
recipes and their because because
they're clever because the system has
been designed in this way if two of the
recipes require garlic you will get the
amount of garlic that you need for both
recipes no more no less you have exactly
what you need but not too much and I
love it when I don't waste food some of
the meals available in January include
spaghetti squash and marinara with
mushrooms and garlic knots and the one
that I made last week or the week before
spicy shrimp and Korean rice cakes with
cabbage delicious excellent really
really liked it and it's not something I
would really ever think of making on my
own if I'm just wandering through the
grocery store grabbing ingredients you
can check out this week's menu and this
is great
get your first three meals for free with
free shipping of course by going to blue
apron comm slash Pakman it will taste
good it will feel good and you'll learn
something about cooking that you might
not otherwise know blue apron comm slash
Pakman PA KMA and support blue apron and
support the David Pakman show